honestly the story that i think is more
indicative for more americans today than
impeachment
uh is actually a story that seems rather
minor on the surface
it seems rather mine around the surface
except that we have literally tens of
millions of people in the united states
who are afraid that the canceled culture
is coming up for them and cancel culture
does exist
okay the culture of we are going to get
you fired because we don't like your
social media posts
not even social media posts that are
extraordinarily horrific
you know the kind of stuff that would
get you shunned in polite society just
stuff that
is a little edgy right that kind of
stuff that has impact
on hundreds of millions of americans
okay because we have
in the united states a an iron triangle
between the democratic party and the
media and corporations
okay that iron triangle goes something
like this the media and the democrats
agree on virtually everything
democrats have an agenda the media push
that agenda and then the media and
democrats pressure corporations to do
their bidding
in order that they can foster that
agenda so unofficially they are allowed
to use threats
in order to make clear what exactly they
want to happen okay so what this results
in
very very often is corporations looking
to cram down a particular viewpoint on
you
and then cancel you right that is what
many americans are feeling
today there are polls out there that
show that a vast majority of americans
in every single political group
including liberals except for people on
the hard left
feel like they cannot say what they want
to say in public because they are afraid
that they are going to be canceled
fired cast out from polite society hey
that is a real phenomenon is taking
place every single day and i will say it
is amusing to watch as some people on
the hard left get canceled and then they
turn around and they're like why aren't
people defending me
we are it's just that you guys created
this society this actually happened
to a socialist named nathan
robinson he got canceled
from the guardian and he said he got
canceled from the guardian because he
had
put up some anti-israel tweet okay now i
think he's an idiot i think that his
views on israel are abhorrent
but i don't think that he should lose
his columnist slot over at the guardian
he certainly would not defend anybody on
the other side who got cancelled in fact
he has repeatedly said canceled culture
does not exist okay it does exist
the fact that there are people out there
who want you to lose your job
for the sin of saying things they don't
agree with is extraordinarily real and
it is happening
on a moment-by-moment basis the latest
example of this is gina carano so gina
carano
is one of the stars of the mandalorian
she plays a character called cara dune
and gina carrano was a former mma star
and then she was in a movie called
haywire
in which she sort of made her acting
debut she's been in a bunch of stuff
since then and then her biggest role to
date was as carotune in the mandalorian
so she's sort of the ally of the
mandalorian who's played by pedro pascal
now apparently back in november
according to the hollywood reporter
there was talk about giving her her own
spin-off show because disney plus has
decided to move
into a bunch of star wars spin-offs
right just like the mandalorian
well then they decided we're not going
to do that anymore you know we've
decided that we're not going to do that
apparently they had decided that back in
november
because she had made some social media
posts about president trump
and this made them very angry and so
they essentially removed
that possibility okay so again
this is according to the hollywood
reporter quote this is not the first
time carano who played former rebel
alliance
soldier cara dune on the mandalorian has
been the focus of social media ire for
her political comments
last november she issued contentious
tweets one in which she mocked mask
wearing amid the novel coronavirus
pandemic another in which she falsely
suggested that voter fraud occurred
during the 2020 presidential election a
source with knowledge of lucasfilm's
thinking
told the hollywood reporter quote
they've been looking for a reason to
fire her for two months
today was the final straw okay so
finally they got
cara dune right they finally got keratin
they finally got
gina carano by the way what were those
old tweets that were so terrible
so she apparently tweeted on november
14th 2020
democratic govern government leaders now
recommend we wear blindfolds along with
masks so we really can't see what's
going on
okay that is not something that is
cancelable on november 5th
she tweeted out we need to clean up the
election process so we are not left
feeling the way we do today
put in place laws that protect us
against voter fraud investigate every
state film the accounting flush out fake
votes require id
make voter fraud end in 2020 fix the
system
that's not controversial i'm sorry that
is not controversial
saying that you have to protect against
voter fraud with things like voter id
and filming counting
and fleshing out fake votes that is not
controversial okay so
they they are saying that they had meant
to cancel her all the way back in
november
for those kinds of posts which are
slightly edgy but not frankly all that
edgy
okay then she posted the final straw so
what exactly was the final straw
she posted on instagram it was a picture
of a jewish woman
running away from from nazi
soldiers okay and here's what she wrote
jews were beaten in the streets not by
nazi soldiers but by their neighbors
even by children sad face right sad
emoji and then it's a quote that says
because history is edited
most people today don't realize that to
get to the point where nazi soldiers
could easily round up thousands of jews
the government first made their own
neighbors hate them simply for being
jews how is that any different from
hating someone for their political views
okay that is not her making light of the
holocaust okay like as the as your
official jewish friend
right as an orthodox jew let me just say
i don't like holocaust comparisons i
don't i think that virtually all of them
are overwrought
i think that very few of them really are
uh
are accurate i think most of them ignore
historical context i think virtually all
of them
liken things that are not like the
holocaust to the holocaust i don't think
the liberals in the united states are on
the verge
of rounding jews up and sending them to
concentration camps for example
with that said this post is an overall
holocaust comparison it is not a
fireable offense it is not even close to
a fireball offense
her saying that neighbors should treat
people decently because if you don't
treat your political neighbors decently
you can be roped into doing things that
are evil which is the general point
that happens to not be a general point
that is wrong it's just that it ought
not be done in the context of a
holocaust comparison again i don't like
holocaust comparisons is that a fireable
offense
okay so let me give that a little bit of
a flavor is that a fireball offense our
overwrought holocaust comparisons right
comparisons that should not be made
that are inappropriately made to the
holocaust are those fireable offenses
well
um let me just mention that there is
another star of the mandalorian his name
is pedro pascal
or pedro pascal has recently trended
because he is a leftist on politics
and because he has expressed support for
transgender
transgender rights and all of this and
so this makes him very popular in in the
twitter verse also he's very
progressive on issues like immigration
here is a tweet that pedro pascal
put out on june 20th 2018. hashtag this
is america
it is a picture on the top of germany in
1944 a bunch of jews
standing behind barbed wire in a
concentration camp america 2018
it is a picture of a bunch of kids in in
cages
right that is so the comparison is kids
in cages and germany 1944. you know
except for the fact that we are housing
and making sure that those kids
are okay as opposed to you know gassing
them to death
that comparison is perfectly appropriate
but was there an iota
of comment about pedro pascal of course
not gina caron just got fired
she just got fired she also lost her job
at uta so uta is
representing her so she didn't lose her
job they represent her right uta is an
agency they represent her and they
dumped her on the side of the road
disney plus has decided that gina carano
can no longer be associated with disney
plus
because she made an overall holocaust
comparison that happens to be of the
right
if you make an overwrought holocaust
comparison you're the left if you call
trump hitler if you suggest that
that kids who are being who are being
kept separate from their parents in
accordance with the flores settlement by
the way
if if they d that that is like the
holocaust you're totally fine
we're going to get some more of this in
just one second because it is indicative
of where we are in the culture and it is
a terrible moment for american culture
and yes this is more indicative for more
americans of what is going on in their
daily lives
than many of the things that are being
said in the capitol building today
okay and that is not to make light of
the impeachment and is not to make light
of what happened on january 6th
it is to say that social movements have
consequences and we are now in the
middle of a mass social movement
to expel half of the american population
from the body politic
okay so according to the hollywood
reporter
karana will not be returning to the
mandalorian or the star wars galaxy
after sharing a post on social media
implying that being a republican today
is like being jewish
during the holocaust gina carrano is not
currently employed by luca's film and
there are no plans for her to be in the
future a lucas film spokesperson said in
a statement
nevertheless her social media posts
denigrating people based on their
cultural and religious identities are
abhorrent and unacceptable i have a
question
like really this is a question who got
denigrated based on cultural and
religious identity
hey i don't understand is the suggestion
that when you say that people should not
treat
other people the way that germans
treated jews prior to the holocaust
that that is denigrating jews in some
way
she's saying what happened to jews is
bad i don't like the comparison because
i again i don't like overall holocaust
comparisons but
is that is that denigrating i don't feel
denigrated
i'm both culturally and religiously
jewish in fact i'm one of those jewish
people i know
hard to find people more jewish than i
am i wear the hat and everything
i do not feel denigrated by gina
carano's
instagram post i feel again
like it was overwrought so i think it's
a fireable offense
okay also let's just talk about things
that are denigrating
and um and abhorrent and unacceptable
okay so disney plus
has now canceled gina carano for the
great son of an instagram post that they
find inappropriate
okay from the same people who are
constantly denigrating
conservatives i mean like on a regular
basis but in any case
you know what's actually comparable to
the holocaust
you know the most comparable one of the
most comfortable things happening on
planet earth right now to the holocaust
the rounding up of uyghur muslims in
china and sending them to concentration
camps and then forcibly sterilizing the
women
as reported by the associated press that
is one of the most similar things you
can have to the holocaust
what would you say if i told you that
disney plus in the credits to mulan
thanked the zhanzhan government which is
the province in china
where they are currently holding uighur
muslims in concentration camps
and they thanked let disney plus thanked
the chinese government
now which seems more counselable to you
working with a government that is
forcibly sterilizing muslim women on the
basis of their religion
which is kind of like the holocaust like
without the exaggeration or the
overwrought of it
that that's really a lot like the
holocaust actually
which is more like that that or gina
carano
put out a social media meme that
included a holocaust comparison just
like pedro pascal did a couple of years
ago but pedro pascal is good because
he's on the left
and gina carano is really bad because
she's not on the left
so uta has now also dropped the actor
on wednesday the hashtag fire gina
carano was trending following that
instagram post
the post has since been deleted
screenshots were widely shared by users
on social media who called for her
firing from the hit disney plus
star wars show now again she deleted the
post so it's not even like she left it
up right she deleted the post
and that's still not enough because
that's the way that this works the
minute that you delete the post it's not
as though absolution is granted to you
it's not as though oh you know what i
was overwrought that was a mistake i
took it down
nope this is just an excuse to beat to
beat the living hell out of you
according to sources lucasfilm plan to
unveil carano as a star of her own
disney plus series during a december
investors day presentation but scrapped
those plans
following her november tweet in which
she suggested that we ought to protect
against voter fraud and also
in which she suggested that the media
were essentially blinding you to some
things that were true
multiple mandalorian spin-offs are in
the works from executive producers john
favreau and david filoni
including rangers of the new republic
which could have potentially started
carano
after the latest round of social media
posts the decision to cut ties with the
actor
came swiftly there is a damned shocker
there is an unbelievable shocker so it
is not a shocker at all of course
but it is indicative of the world in
which we live
and everybody knows that they are on the
hook for this
this is the prevailing wind of our
culture right now
if your corpora if if you're a
corporation the one that hires you
finds out that 10 years ago you posted
something that is now out of fashion
let's say that back in 2008 for example
you supported
traditional marriage in the state of
california and that comes out now in
2021 you could lose your job
why do i say that because that's exactly
what happened to brandon aish who is the
ceo of mozilla firefox that happened
just a few years ago when he held the
exact same position on proposition 8
that a man named barack obama did at the
time
right the the the attempt to cancel
anyone and everyone because the
standards are constantly shifting and
constantly moving but really only people
on one side of the aisle
is ongoing did you know that every like
on this video creates one additional
leftist tier don't ask me why that's
called science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button